في السابع من اغسطس عام 2022 اغتالت
اسرائيل القائد العسكريه للمنطقه الجنوبيه
في سرايا القدس التابعه لحركه الجهاد خالد
منصور وتم ذلك بغاره استهدفت عددا من
المنازل في مدينه رفح يعد منصور من اوائل
مؤسسي سرايا القدس في قطاع غزه وسبق ان
توعده رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيليال وقبل استشهاده بيومين اغتيل
القيادي البارز في حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
تيسير الجعبري في قصف اسرائيلي استهدف شقه
سكنيه في برج فلسطين في غزه وكان الجعفري
من ابرز القاده العسكريين لسرايا القدس
الذراع العسكري لحركه الجهاد وقائد
المنطقه الشماليه في قطاع غزه ونجا قبلها
من محاولتي اغتيال في
2012-14
وقبل تولي الجعبري قياده المنطقه الشماليه
لسرايا القدس كانت هذه المهمه على عاتق
الشهيد بهاء ابو العطا الذي اغتيل بدوره
في الثاني عش نوفمبر عام 2019 مع زوجته في
قصف صاروخي اسرائيلي المركز على منزله في
حي الشجاعيه بغزه وكانت اسرائيل تحمله
المسؤوليه عن العمليات التي تنفذها سرايا
القدس وقد نجا قبل استشهاده من محاولات
اسرائيليه عده اغتياله اله الاغتيال
الاسرائيليه طالت في الحادي والعشرين من
اغسطس عام 2014 القائد العسكريه للواء رفح
في كتائب عز الدين القسام رائد العطار فقد
استهدفت طائرات اسرائيليه مبنى سكانيا كان
موجودا فيه بغزه وسبقت اغتياله اربع
محاولات اسرائيليه فاشله وعرف عن العطار
انه كان مهندس اختطاف الجندي الاسرائيلي
بين يدي حركه حماس وفي القصف الاسرائيلي
نفسه استشهد محمد ابو شماله وكان مسؤول
دائره الامداد والتجهيز في كتائب عز الدين
القسام ومن الرعين الاول المؤسس ل لكتائب
كما وصفته حماس وفي الرابعه عشر من نوفمبر
عام 2012 اغتيل احمد الجعبري نائب القائد
العام لكتائب القسام وذلك بصاروخ
اسرائيليين استهدف سيارته في مدينه غزه
وكان قد نجا قبلها من محاولات اغتيال عده
شملت قصف منزله خلال الهجوم الاسرائيلي
على غزه عام 2012